[Applauso]
vi voglio raccontare una storia che
conoscete bene nell'inverno del
2021 un dipolo di pressione si è
piazzato sopra l'Europa quindi un'alta
pressione da nord-ovest giù fino a
sudest
a quei sistemi meteorologici che
normalmente portano acqua e neve sul
Continente poi sulla nostra penisola di
arrivare e quindi non è piovuto non è
ricato gli agricoltori si sono allarmati
in dicembre del 2021 Forse vi
ricorderete già si parlava di meno della
metà dell'accumulo nervoso che di solito
si ha sull'arco Alpino e anche sull'alta
Valle del Po quell'acqua che poi da neve
diventa acqua liquida in primavera
quando si scioglie alimenta il grande
fiume proprio nel momento in cui serve
per l'irrigazione quindi gli agricoltori
erano abbastanza allarmati Ci arrivò
gennaio febbraio a questo punto era
abbastanza chiaro che c'era un problema
serio poi la Russia ha invaso l'Ucraina
è venuto a piovere e un po' come neve al
sole la preoccupazione sulla sicit è
evaporata se n'è andata dal dibattito
pubblico ma in realtà non era affatto
passata tant'è che alla fine di marzo
dalle secche del Po emerge un
semicingolato tedesco Questo era un caro
armato che i tedeschi avevano affossato
affondato nelle acque del Po Quando
erano in ritirata nel
1945 E da allora non era mai emerso
eccetto Appunto nel maggio del 2022 nel
marzo del 2022 Scusate tra Modena e
Reggio arriva aprile maggio giugno a
questo punto gli agricoltori stanno
tirando fuori dal po' vi ricorderete il
fiume è andato in secca varie volte le
temperature erano molto alte quindi si
Riv acqua per per
irrigare a giugno c'è l'emergenza a
luglio le temperature fanno spaccare La
Marmolada il grande ghiacciaio che è
rimasto dal dall'ultima glaciazione
Purtroppo travolgendo alcuni
escursionisti che passavano che
passavano sotto ad agosto ad agosto
siamo nel 2022 il paese è m a secco il
governo dichiara
l'emergenza si chiamano le elezioni due
settimane prima delle
elezioni comincia a piovere il Misa
fiume marchigiano esonda e mette
sott'acqua Senigaglia distruzione a cose
persone La siccità scompare dal
dibattito pubblico non se ne sente più
parlare adesso c'è il problema delle
alluvioni il problema del rischio
idrogeologico di quello parliamo si
attraversano le elezioni senza senza che
si parlasse di siccità ottobre e
novembre ci preoccupiamo delle bombe
d'acqua le famose cosiddette bombe
d'acqua una delle quali cade e colpisce
in pieno Ischia dove poi crolla un pezzo
della montagna travolgendo case e
facendo facendo
vittime Ovviamente la Si cità non era
finita tant'è che alla fine dell'anno in
dicembre 2022 siamo da capo gli
agricoltori notano che non c'è accumulo
particolarmente sull'alta Valle del Po
Men 70% di accumulo Nevoso siamo di
nuovo in pericolo A questo punto la cosa
si fa seria perché le produzioni
agricole si rischiano di essere in
stress per 2 anni consecutivi gennaio
febbraio 2023 i giornali parlano di
siccità a questo punto preghiamo per
l'acqua Speriamo che venga a piovere lo
diciamo tutti qualcosa qualcuno ci
ascolta perché poi arriviamo a maggio e
le fose cataratte del cielo si aprono e
scendono particolarmente sulla Romagna
in tre giorni la quantità di di acqua
che di solito scende in metà anno la
distruzione spaventosa naturalmente 30 e
più fiumi esondano migliaia di frane
lungo tutto l'arco appenninico e
pedemontano 8 miliardi di euro si
stima di di danni ed Allora continuiamo
in questa danza tra momenti osi e caldi
in cui ci preoccupiamo di avere
abbastanza acqua e momenti in cui poi
scendono queste forti precipitazioni che
interrompono la nostra vita anche qua a
Milano anche recentemente
ora Questo non è un problema solamente
italiano avrete visto in settembre del
2023 il ciclone d'agnolo è partito dalla
Grecia ha fatto danni in Turchia in
Bulgaria in Grecia in tessagli
Addirittura ha lasciato un lago che non
c'era prima poi ha attraversato il
Mediterraneo ha virato verso la Libia
verso la Siren ha colpito Derna
tragicamente facendo collassare due
dighe che si sono portate via nel giro
di pochi minuti migliaia di persone ma
non c'è dubbio che l'Italia in
particolare si è scoperta vulnerabile in
questi ultimi anni si è
scoperta vulnerabile e cosa sta
succedendo cosa sta succedendo Beh
stanno succedendo due cose importanti La
prima Presumo ne avete sentito parlare e
cioè che il clima sta
cambiando il clima si esprime sul
territorio attraverso l'acqua le l'
alluvioni le grandi precipitazioni
leicità la lunghezza dcit Queste sono
espressioni del clima sul
territorio la statistica di questi
eventi è il clima se il clima Cambia
Cambia Questa statistica nessuno di
quegli eventi che vi ho descritto può
essere attribuito esattamente e
unicamente al cambiamento climatico Ma
la statistica di questi eventi Eh sta
cambiando esattamente come ci
aspettavamo ormai da da anni da più di
anni ma c'è un'altra cosa che sta
succedendo che è molto importante E cioè
che le istituzioni e infrastrutture che
noi avevamo disegnato e costruito per
anni per proteggerci da quella
statistica per
contenere quella variabilità quelle
istituzioni e quelle infrastrutture
stanno fallendo
quelle istituzioni quelle infrastrutture
che sono fondamentali nella vita di
tutti noi è per questo che Presumo
nessuno di voi guadi un fiume quando va
al lavoro è per questo che tutti noi
possiamo aprire un rubinetto in cucina e
avere l'acqua senza dover andare al
fiume la mattina con un secco quelle
infrastrutture quelle istituzioni si
stanno rivelando non più correttamente
dimensionate per gestire la variabilità
che si sta
manifestando
Allora a questo punto vi dovreste
chiedere ma da dove vengono queste
infrastrutture e queste istituzioni
prendiamo la Romagna per esempio queste
infrastrutture sono il prodotto di un
processo storico di un processo storico
in cui ogni generazione ha trasformato
il
territorio per sostenere un particolare
progetto sociale politico economico la
storia Parte da lontano in Romagna
appunto addirittura la ROM fu disboscata
dai Romani 2000 anni fa per sostenere
l'urbanizzazione
e la coltivazione della pianura n 1400
per esempio la casa d'est di Ferrara
trasformò la Romagna e fiumi Romagnoli
in funzione di un progetto politico di
espansione ed economico poco tempo dopo
il
Reno fiume che una volta era un
affluente del Po è stato reindirizzato
attraverso il cavo benedettino In un
vecchio ramo antico del po il poom morto
di primaro e fatto defluire
nell'Adriatico creando da un affluente
un fiume indipendente e poi nell'800
alla fine
dell'800 durante governo De Pretis tutta
l'Italia cominciò a implementare grandi
opere di bonifica anche Romania si
cominciò la bonifica che continuò Fino
alla metà del XX secolo fino al 1950
trasformando quindi quella che era stata
storicamente Una palude in uno dei
territori agricoli produttivi
industrializzati della penisola della
penisola italiana fino naturalmente a
maggio di quest'anno quando è tutto è
tutto classato ogni
generazione ha creato il proprio futuro
trasformando quel territorio e adesso
che si fa Questa è la domanda e adesso
che si fa no
e qui si rischia un equivoco e cioè che
voi tutti noi
tutti ci si giri verso persone come me
scienziati E chiediate cosa ci dice La
scienza cosa dobbiamo
fare ma la scienza l'ingegneria la
tecnica offrono risposte ma non possono
selezionare la domanda e la domanda la
domanda centrale nell'affrontare questi
cambiamenti che stanno
succedendo È semplice ed è
questa cosa volete vedere vo
collettivamente quando Guardate fuori
dalla finestra che territorio volete per
ilost Futur che cosa volete ved crescere
attorno alle nostre città come volete
vedere
gestite le nostre risor n paesaggio
queste domande non sono domand
scientifiche sono domand profondamente
Politi profondamente
politiche quando mi si chiede Cosa posso
fare rispetto al cambiamento climatico
spesso si cercano risposte come Beh
facciamo una doccia più breve Oppure
chiudiamo il rubinetto mentre ci laviamo
i denti cerchiamo di risparmiare acqua e
Quelle sono cose importanti da fare per
carità ma non sta lì non sta lì la
soluzione in un paese alla frontiera del
clima quello che serve è atto di
Cittadinanza e impegno civico
Impegnatevi nei comuni a capire come
viene gestito il vostro territorio
Impegnatevi nelle discussioni delle
Autorità Bacino Impegnatevi nella
politica in modo che i partiti non
possano ignorare il problema del
paesaggio e passare un'elezione senza
preoccuparsi della siccità
l'ambientalismo il preoccuparsi del
clima deve essere un atto civico è un
atto civico l'ambientalismo deve essere
un atto civico nel quale tutti assieme
come persone che abitano in un
condominio e devono gestire il
pianerottolo e il giardino il cortile e
la terrazza in comune devono sedersi
attorno un tavolo e trovare una sintesi
politica al nostro vivere assieme nel
nostro territorio la cittadinanza attiva
è l'unica soluzione nella gestione del
nostro futuro in un paese in un mondo
che cambia
Grazie la